welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for this opportunity to engage with
panelists on the benefits and challenges
of cannabis in pediatric conditions in
legal states it's my pleasure to
introduce our participants who will be
available to answer your questions
following this discussion our panelists
include Janelle Donovan Cara Osborne and
Don wells for more information about our
participants please refer to the speaker
biographies in the center of your screen
my name is dr. Kenton Crowley and I will
be the moderator for today's discussion
this session is interactive so please
submit your questions by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box we will
address your questions via email
following the discussion now I'd like to
introduce our panelists Janel Donovan
she's the mother of Regan a six year old
daughter that has a genetic disorder
called Rhett syndrome as well as a
seizure disorder Janelle is the CEO of
Angie a company which she founded and
was born from the necessity in a
hospital at Reagan's bed site Hera is
the mother of a mother 2 to 15 year old
twins that have fragile X syndrome the
leading cause of autism
she works for Silver State training
based out of Sparks Nevada for the past
two years and is currently the Sales
Manager era is an advocate and speaker
regarding the use of cannabis and autism
and other developmental disabilities and
rare diseases Don wells is a board
member
Reilly's smile foundation and she is a
former police officer Don has a 16 year
old daughter Kennedy who has autism
epilepsy juvenile rheumatoid arthritis
is disabled and lives in pain daily so
what I'd like to start with let's start
with Janelle can you tell us what
brought you into being a kanima yeah
it's pretty simple
my daughter has Rett syndrome and then
separately a mass in her brain that
caused epilepsy so we kind of got we had
some developmental delays and then all
of a sudden we were hit with a pretty
big diagnosis at about two years old and
her seizures hit first and we we had an
ER doctor that did an MRI and was like
there's a mass in the brain and that was
on top of the Rhett syndrome diagnosis
and kind of my understanding of it is
you know the the brain is pretty complex
but abnormal activity is abnormal
activity and there's epileptic and
non-epileptic it's kind of defined a lot
by the medications we have to treat
things so we have medicine for the
epileptic and we don't for the non
technically and when reagan's seizures
hit it also sparks her non-epileptic
brain activity that is Rhett syndrome
and she stopped sleeping it was a little
bit out of a scene like The Exorcism
where she was up all night and she was
crazy and Pharma drugs didn't work they
made her worse and at that point we we
were desperate we were willing to try
anything I think when your your kid's
not sleeping and the family isn't
sleeping and she was self harming and
she was obviously in distress her brain
was going crazy so we kind of had
seizures we dealt with the seizures
pretty quickly things calmed down and
then the the Goliath appeared and the
Goliath has no treatment
Rett syndrome is currently considered
untreatable and incurable commonality
with autism is the
brain activity that's not epileptic and
it's quite severe so the result of that
period of time which is generally called
a regression is you lose all ability to
swallow to walk to use your hands and
you know we just cared about sleep at
first so I had a friend and we had some
medicine sent to us and it was full
plant and we weren't afraid to go high
on dosing and fell into kind of knowing
what was gonna work for her really
quickly in terms of high THC in full
plant initially we were about passing
her out and the the dosing was quite
scary at first except for when it worked
and then we figured out what actually
got her to sleep and didn't care about a
number the number was arbitrary to to us
and then we thought we we really saw
that carry over to the day and all of a
sudden we saw that she woke up calmer
and she wasn't staring at the sky she
was looking at me again and she was
using her hands and we've been living
the world of kind trying to keep that
presence and awareness we use cannabis
to keep our daughter's presence at the
end of the day if what we found is if we
can keep presents all of the other
bodily functions continue to function as
they should in terms of swallow and
hands and walking and and so that was
really where our journey began was
carrying over this great gift that was
given to us that gave us sleep but then
seeing how it really carried over to
morning so and then we've been on that
journey for the last five years ever
since so great gone why don't you tell
us about what led you down this path the
cannabis well kind of like Janelle I was
kind of at my wit's end with Kennedy I
kind of had the same thing Kennedy had
started with seizures when when she was
a baby
and they were undiagnosed and then
the the doctor was holding her when she
was a toddler and and she had a seizure
in his in his arms and it was she it was
it was just a partial complex seizures
and then and then she ended up having
she she has four different types of
seizures she has dropped seizures she
she has all different kinds of seizures
and none no medication is is able to
control them so she's on all tight and
then now she ends up she's allergic to
all the medications to the seizure
medications so we we don't know what to
do we've we've had her on all these
medications and we tried every single
different kind we don't know what to do
with them she's chief has you know
several seizures a day
none of them are grand mal seizures
however she's having you know sometimes
she'll have ten seizures a day sometimes
she'll have twenty seizures a day
sometimes we don't even know how many
seizures that she's having that we don't
know about and then on top of that she's
autistic and she's she's not she's going
through times where she's not sleeping
she's had four brain surgeries so the
neurological side of it her brain has
been affected so in in ways that we
don't know that that due to the
surgeries and everything because she has
so much scar tissue up there that that
she doesn't sleep half the time
so we were we were dosing her up with
melatonin we were we she wouldn't she
would just start screaming in the middle
of the night we didn't know what was
wrong she was in pain she'd start
banging her head and a friend of mine I
just I am
I heard the radio this this
advertisement for it was for a
fundraiser and it was for Riley Smile
Foundation and it was it was just a
thing for for an event and I was big
into fundraising and it was something
that had just started and I started
talking to to Riley's mom and she got me
into it and she had just started hurt
her daughter had cancer and she just
started with with the dosing and and
everything and she she's like we'll try
it and she had somebody out in Colorado
that was helping her and sending her
some stuff and everything and we just we
just started we we started Kennedy out
on on small stuff and then and then we
just built her up built her up built her
up and and it's helping it's it's
helping but she needs Delaware laws are
very she doesn't have a card she doesn't
have a medical card she can't get one
because she has because because of what
she has so Delaware hasn't approved it
yet so we're on a different side of it
it's it's very it's it's hard it's tough
it's very tough so Kennedy's on the on
the
jeez we're getting ready to go to to
Legislative Hall right now to do an
addendum to the to Reilly's law to get
the to get the law changed and
everything so
so Kennedy's getting it under a
different a different area so just like
so but it's helping and and I'm and
we're doing the best that we can with
her and everything it and it's tough
it's very tough though I'm just trying
I'm new to all of this and I'm trying to
soak up every little bit that I can all
the information I can on it and this
would mean to use cannabis oh how long
ago do you want how long ago was it did
you engaged with Riley's I've been with
Riley smile foundation for three years
and she started in but Kennedy didn't
get to start using it until this past
year okay so it's just been a little bit
yeah
oh yeah very recent well Hara why don't
you tell us about what where how long it
took you in why you turned to you know
cannabis as a treatment solution for
your twins so much like Janelle and Dawn
story with their children our need well
let me back up I have twins that have
something called 15 year old twins that
have something called fragile X syndrome
which is the leading genetic cause of
Isis of them and so it is a blood test
we know exactly what it is they know
exactly what's wrong it's a CJD repeat a
higher number repeats the more
profoundly affected the child is because
my son
as one X chromosome he is severely
affected so this is my son I don't know
can you guys see that yeah long okay
that's my daughter and this is both of
them for a rare disease day but I wanted
to show you pictures because I think
it's important but with fragile X
chromosome he's nonverbal at 15 still in
diapers much like to know my Janelle's
daughter my son doesn't sleep so he were
her it's because he doesn't sleep he's
in fighter flight 24 hours a day seven
days a week so his body is in flexion so
we were in the position his dad is a
major league baseball player so he was
traveling and he was on for eight
straight and DJ is his name wasn't
sleeping and so a friend of mine at the
time had some had one of the top tell
stories in the country though people
were coming to her and bring her CBD and
THC heard of my twins and they you know
she needs to try this and it was this
you know vial of Medicine this syringe
and the in that syringe was something
called RSO Rick Simpson oil which is
some of the heaviest most potent THC
available also the meet in Cana so we
gave him a little a half of a race ran
on a piece of banana popped him in his
mouth within the hour he was asleep and
slept through the night
it changed our lives literally changed
our lives because he woke up ready
available rested happy not lethargic
strung out angry head hitting
self-interest behaviors I was so
reluctant for so long so we were not
go state at that time recreational we
hadn't even started the licenses for
dispensaries and I was getting the
medicine in California and the medicine
was inconsistent and at the time I was
so judgmental because I wasn't on this
side of the business and now to
understand way I do its agriculture so
sometimes they'd be like tart and other
times it would be like maple syrup when
I was giving it to my son and so it's
inconsistent so I felt the need to get
involved in making the medicine bringing
it to people being a voice that never
grew up trying ever and was completely
against it and so okay I'm sorry I was
reading that and so anyways it changed
the course of our lives
and now I am a big advocate because both
of my kids take tinctures ratio based
insures and also take a medicine by the
name of trophy because it's super fast
acting and my son takes Rick Simpson oil
to this day and I'm very fortunate Don
my heart goes out to you I'm very
fortunate because we live in Nevada
where it's recreational and all I can
say is just keep fighting you know there
there's no handbook and there's nothing
out there that shows you the map to get
to where you have to be but at some
point in time that people that you're
talking to you are going to need this
medicine and it's it might not be now
but at some point in time someone they
love is going to need it so your voice
needs to remain strong because you know
that this works and there's an idiot
numbers and and the journey is not easy
it really isn't but you're making a huge
difference I mean there's so many times
I wanted to stop and turn around where
people would judge right but they have
the same medicine to see them five
medicine it's trazadone
you know we're spirit on all these
different medications and they're all
different
Rhett syndrome Down syndrome fragile axe
just a each all these things you know a
friend of mine her kids having a genetic
rare disease and we stopped their
glowing white light a savior medicines
but yet cannabis is a lock and key
system right it goes to exactly where it
needs to go for all three of my all of
our kids I have two that are on it so
for four of our children and it works
it's just breaking the barriers and
being that voice of reason that why does
this have to be illegal or so difficult
to access or so expensive to access this
is something that genuinely works for
our children mm-hmm nothing have you
worked for my son before tell us what
comes to your mind when you hear you
know Don and inheres story and how it
relates to your challenge we all walk a
very similar walk you know we're all
dealing with conditions that mostly are
considered untreatable they can kind of
match to a couple medicines a couple of
symptoms but really at the heart of it
the abnormal non-epileptic brain
activity is considered untreatable by
modern medicine and that's the bottom
line the common denominator between all
of our syndromes and diseases and
everything that's wrong neuro land is on
is clears day in an EEG you have a
normal AG or you have an abnormal EEG
and so it's baffling to me yet we all
face such similar journeys but very hard
roadblocks and barriers to entry I can't
tell you how many parents are so afraid
of the broad spectrum of cannabinoid
especially teach see is being a hide you
know a topic that a lot of parents it's
hard for them to cross over the barrier
you hear great things about CBD and you
want to you want to utilize the plant
and there's there's a ton of science you
know when I first started this journey I
just went straight to Google but not
Google there were no like mommy blogs I
was I was in the land of research and I
was reading papers and a lot of coming
out of Israel and I read the research
that showed that our brain has a
receptor for THC and because I was
trying to understand well why does my
kidney THC and she doesn't need just th
species a boatload of it and when we're
when we're dosing for Regan she has one
of from genetic standpoint Regan has the
worst mutation that they've kind of
documented in Rett syndrome there's a
broad spectrum of mutations but Regan
has one of the worst mutations of Rett
syndrome out on top of that a separately
cause epilepsy diagnosis anyone will
tell you about you know early onset
seizures is bad right if you've got
autism these are you know the main
though two sides of the brain don't play
nicely together once your kid ceases
I've got three days of rehabbing because
the non-epileptic brain activity goes
through the roof I mean I live it daily
um and so we had a double whammy when
she was 2 and my my my thing with
parents and anyone looking to get into
this space we all have such different
children but there are huge common
denominators is I really like to try and
narrow it so what are you trying to
treat and no one is going to help you
figure that out your doctors not I mean
I can't - in full disclosure Regan still
doesn't have a medical card even though
we should and we've gone through quite
the battle the last two years with her
acutely and medically and it just hasn't
been on the priority list ultimately
none of her doctors will touch what
we're doing with cannabis because
there's no reason that Regan shouldn't
have a g-tube by now being a wheelchair
have lost full control of her hands and
basically almost all of her presents and
so every doctor that comes across her
says don't whatever you're doing don't
stop
and so we kind of it became less
important to me to go to a doctor we
consulted one very early on because when
I was trying to treat her seizures would
just be be alone
it required a different level of dosing
and and it requires a lot more tracking
than when I was treating Rett syndrome I
was treating big symptoms is she crazy
or she calm you know is she looking at
me or she looking at the ceiling these
are this is mommy science this isn't you
know I think there's a you've got to
find the balance and even to this day
we're very complicated in what we do and
some days I just want to throw it all
away and just go how is she doing
and how does she look and how does she
feel when I touch her and sometimes I
doze from the heart and you know I go I
kind of ebb and flow between those
worlds but there's no in the beginning
we were trying to maintain Reagan's
presence and we're trying to still to
this day we're dosing her to maintain or
bodily control though Reagan shouldn't
be walking to this day and every time we
have a medical issue that causes
seizures she's at risk for not walking
again and we continually live in a
battle of keeping her you know she's
never aspirated in her life but that's
something that's very common scoliosis
is also very common in Rhett syndrome
and she is to this day my daughter is
six years old and she has none of the
markers of Rhett syndrome from a
clinical perspective so she hasn't lost
full hand control and those are things
that I still go for every day
ultimately I may get more but you know
how let me you've heard dawn these
scenarios and challenges you're in a
spot that even makes it more challenging
to access material that you know I want
to ask you all what are the challenges
that that you find getting consistent
product and let's oh no we lost on well
Don go ahead and
and 12 you know how your how you're
dealing with that situation getting the
product well I I get it actually through
Jani J meddler who gets it through she
gets it for her daughter and she gets it
it's it's kind of through the through
the vine I have to do it through that
way and if it wasn't if it wasn't being
for being involved with Riley's small
foundation and me not in it and its cost
a lot of money that's that's the bat
already cost a lot of money and I do
have a good neurologist for her that
that I can that will probably be able to
get a cart for her it's very suiting for
her but but the problem like then about
her neurologist is saying is that that
the dosages that that she needs to to
keep her to help her because of the pain
that she's in because of her arthritis
and and then the her other neurological
issues conditions and stuff that she has
she needs very high dosages and then
she's got her seizure disorder and then
she has her autism so it's different
it's different different strains
different kinds that she needs
so it's like okay she needs all these
different kinds and stuff in it and it
comes to lot of money and then you're
talking about bringing all that in and
that's that's a lot you know like that's
a lot of money I mean that's a car
payment
it's a car payment every month trying to
get that to bring that in every
and and then you know no card and and
say yeah it's tough it's very tough and
it's actually it's it's legal for adults
out here it's legal for adults but not
for children so what's very tough how
have you dealt with supply sourcing what
what have you been successful with
acquiring product for for your kid is
that for me sorry it was breaking up
yeah Hera yeah we were talking about
sourcing and supply yeah yeah it's it's
a bit different for for me because as
soon as I found out that this worked I'd
opened two feet to get really involved
to bring to help create products and to
bring products to the marketplace and
not was my journey to silver state
trading that's located here in Sparks
Nevada they actually produce a product
that I helped create from the beginning
and so sourcing the products first was
very difficult because we were sourcing
it from out of state and it was a
product that was given to us but still
getting a good Rick Simpson oil here is
very difficult because it is
agricultural right and it's it is not
perfect but the consistency of Rick
Simpson oil is is so thick that we've
had to try other things so being able to
find products has been wonderful due to
the fact that I'm right there I can walk
to the back lab and meet with the people
that are doing the research and
development and give them the feedback
as to what is needed so I it was a hard
road to travel for a very long time and
thing is perfect they're still nights
that DJ doesn't sleep he takes he
requires 24-hour round-the-clock care
seven days a week that will never change
you know I don't live for a cure I went
today to make sure that he gets his Rick
Simpson oil and his CBE and like you
said to know a lot of people look at
this and think you know you're giving
your kid cannabis like THC yeah he is he
gets some of the strongest THC available
to man cancer treat patients get it and
that is the only thing that will shut
his little system down to make him relax
to be able to to sleep and it's funny
because six years ago I went to the lead
researcher for his diagnosis who gets
all the grants that she could ever wish
for and I talked to her about cannabis
and now look at them they're doing a a
deal with a synthetic cannabis company
you know they Big Pharma it's not the
same doesn't have the same result still
effects your kidneys so you know when
when people of that magnitude reach out
to me and send people to me to talk to
me it it makes this journey make sense
because it has been one hell of a
journey to get the right medicine and
the right dosing and you know I met with
dr. Crowley and I've talked to dr.
Crowley so many times and this doesn't
make sense what can I do he's not
sleeping he's losing patches of his hair
on his head this big that's because
school district wasn't doing what they
were supposed to be doing and he was
getting injuries at school it wasn't
because of cannabis can you imagine what
would have happened if he didn't have
the cannabis on board that was making
sure that the inflammation was going
down so to answer your question dr. Kent
I've been incredibly blessed by the
journey that we've traveled to be right
here in an area where I can meet with
doctors and Reese
searchers and talk to them and let them
know what's working what's not working
you know what about a different delivery
system the only problem is you know
regulations there you know we can only
do so much you know and and Nevada has
done a good job at regulating things
they've regulated you know gambling and
prostitution and now they've regulated
cannabis but we should it's difficult
because the focus here is so much on rec
but it's still rec or medical patients
cuz it's all people that are going there
need this for medicine whether they
understand it or not you know so it's
it's our children that we're doing this
for but we're breaking down barriers and
doors for people that wouldn't ask these
questions if we didn't have our stories
to share well in in asking about your
the practitioners that you've engaged
with the help with your children's
conditions
Janelle have you had challenges with
getting support for the use of cannabis
with your daughter
have you had doctors report you to child
care services Child Protective Services
of any of you starting with Janelle had
to deal with that other dimension yeah
did I ever ask for permission I never
asked for permission it's my child and
if she's suffering it's my
responsibility to make her better before
anyone else's before a doctor before a
hospital so I guess the big thing with
me was I never asked for permission and
I figured if I was doing the right thing
that that would show because Reagan had
such a double whammy ahead of her and
could have ended up so very different so
very quickly we're talking about being
basically in a semi semi conscious state
two and a half with Everly every bodily
function not in her control
was supposed to be her her that's that
was that was the given right so I never
asked her permission I had a good
pediatrician I let her know what I was
doing and then that was it it was our
neurologist actually locally was the one
that can't I got in touch very early on
because the sleep issue was so severe
and our neurologist was like she reacts
the opposite of every drug that was
supposed to make her asleep made her
worse so he was kind of scratching his
head and he was like I know of this
family in North County and they use high
THC and maybe you want to talk to them
and so I talked to the dad and he was
the first one that made me like not
afraid to go above a hundred and twenty
milligrams I mean if we're talking in
milligrams I had a two year-old daughter
that eventually what passed her out was
a hundred and fifty milligrams 160
milligrams of THC that was only to pass
out for three hours at the time but
really think about what the brain is
doing in a regression of being severe
like Rhett syndrome that is not
surprising so I think we have a tendency
in cannabis to isolate cannabis and go
well this amount is so heavy if you
actually look at the research coming out
with epaulets and the trials going out
without dialects right now the range is
for therapeutic dose thing for epidemics
are like a hundred milligrams to a
thousand you know in in safe ranges why
because cannabis is pretty safe to go
really high and ultimately it comes down
to how crazy is that
EEG one day my daughter had a normal EEG
two weeks later v you're a EEG could
have been like knocking everything out
of the park right I mean that's if we
talked about a body losing the ability
to swallow or losing the ability to walk
that means the brain is really going
crazy so it didn't you know it makes
sense to me intuitively that it would
take such high doses and we found
ourselves very early on if Rick Simpson
oil was really great I'm to this day I
make my own pills at home from three
different sources of medicine
and a little bit of Rick Simpson oil
finds its way in but um ultimately our
journey got really complex because
Reagan was doing so well for so long up
until four years old that no one a lot
of times people didn't think anything
was wrong with her except for the fact
that she was mostly nonverbal and what
ended up hitting us really hard was she
got sick and it went undiagnosed we had
a very bad acid that hit though I I was
very big early on and we found cannabis
and we were treating the brain and we
forgot about the rest of the body and so
my kid had a horrible stomach acid
problem it went undiagnosed because how
does a four-year-old tell you that they
have acid they freaked out they cry you
know all of these things right and it
ended up in a standoff Reagan stopped
eating deliberately for ten days in the
hospital and they thought they tried to
they did a they did what's called a
advanced care meeting would they do that
with parents like us where severe
conditions like Rhett syndrome they go
your child's chronically declining
prepare for the worst and my kid was
just sitting in a hospital going I'm not
gonna take anything else because
something hurts every time you put it
down me and it was this huge standoff
and finally it took us 12 days to get a
GI consult and finally they found out
acid but she was put on 80 MLS of
omeprazole and almost died of e.coli
three months later and well I spread
everywhere and our world changed after
that we're still we're still coming out
of the trauma of basically two years of
hospitalizations nine major infections
two intubations well I almost lost her
more times than I can count
most of the life-saving stuff happened
at home on my watch
so obviously tons of seizures throw in a
couple of statuses here and there and so
my journey just turns because she was
doing so well and I kind of we got
caught off guard by something as benign
as acid and then we didn't we weren't
warned about the effects of antacids and
then you know now here we are two and a
half years later she's alive she has a
chronically declined we survived the
worst of it were rebuilding her health
from the ground up smarter we've revised
cannabis more times than I can't counted
and we use all modes of delivery of it
because to this day if it wasn't for
cannabis Reagan would have died number
one if it wasn't for cannabis she would
have chronically declined number two but
that took a lot of adjusting in acute
situations you know when your kid gained
a seizure coma for 12 days and you know
I was I would you know I was super
dosing her I always changed medicine for
the acute situation so I feel like you
know at times when Reagan first started
to get sick was where we had doctors
start questioning the cannabis
especially when she had a cool and she
was sleeping a lot hour peed started to
turn on me a little bit and it was a
very scary situation we had CP s
involvement several times and I just had
to hold my ground I had to I I kept just
saying something is wrong with my child
I know something is wrong with my child
I treat her genetic condition quite well
with cannabis so she's crying it's
because something is wrong and your job
is to figure it out and you know I was
saying that all the way up until the day
before she almost died at home and then
you know we ended up in the ICU and she
baited and they all come out and they go
oh my gosh she has e.coli and mersa and
I'm like yeah we knew something was
wrong we kept telling you that for
months and you ignored us so what I
always I just stood my ground and I
didn't care if people were questioning
everything I always felt that at the end
of the day if what we were doing was the
right thing for Reagan that that would
show through and you know I felt like at
the end of the day the right thing
always ends up appearing so don't be
afraid about you know what doctors think
and don't be afraid if CPS comes
knocking on your door because if you're
doing the right thing for your child
that doesn't mean that sickness can't
happen that doesn't mean that other
things can't go wrong with their body
but you keep treating their brain
because what happens is if you get
scared and something is going wrong with
the body and you ignore the brain well
the brain will come back to haunt you
have to be acute illness
ordering it and so that's kind of my my
lesson through what we've been through
and never ask for permission it's your
child and you have every right to do
what's right for them no government and
no doctor should ever be able to take
that away I'm sorry you're you go there
what support what were the challenges
that you had with getting physician
support my my big my big challenge with
it was with what this was is that the
hospital here is at first everybody is
on board with with getting the the
cannabis and for children getting
getting this started getting it started
and getting getting the bill passed
getting it all past and and approving it
so so it can be administered for
children and everything so we can get
the cards for the children and stuff it
was all great we're like all right you
can get Kennedy started on this no
problem at all and I had already started
her on it on it you know but I just
couldn't afford to to keep it keep it
going
because it was just too expensive cuz I
have five children and and my other
children aren't you know I've got one
that's that's got hard issues too but so
it hadn't been e it hadn't been an easy
road for me but so every that the
hospital was backing and then all of a
sudden when it came down to it when we
got to to to stand up and and and pass
this this bill and everything and signed
the documents and everything the
hospital all those doctors said no
they weren't gonna pass that they
weren't gonna sign off and and all the
doctors once once everything got passed
once the bill got signed and and
everything well then we went back up and
said and said well you know the
neurologist that that was backing
everything in the beginning he backed
out and said no I'm not gonna I don't
think Kennedy needs it I'm like well
she's a perfect candidate she can't
she's allergic to every single every
single medication that's out there she's
she has adverse reactions just let you
know just like your daughter I mean she
had she they accidentally the pharmacist
the pharmacy a few years ago gave her
the doctor put her on a medication this
medication for whatever one of her
autism medications or whatever they
thought we decided to try try one and
they ended up overdosing her that and
they gave her more than way more than
what an adult should have this child
weighed 60 pounds and they gave her so
much
that that she that she should have been
in a coma and I called the pharmacy and
I'm like I don't know what's wrong she's
just like screaming and she's you know
masochist like she's she's a lunatic
she's I can't control her and he said
well she is autistic I said no this
doesn't have my child next and they said
well well you know I'm sorry but you're
gonna have to get used to it she has
autism and I said you don't know my
child you can't you can't say that you
know this is because of the medication
she just started the medication so I
called I called the hospital because it
was over the weekend I called the
hospital and
they said well what what what dose is
she taking and I told him and and they
said oh my god is she okay because
instead of giving her point O one they
gave her one point O one milligram boy
Wow times more and they said the and
then to top it off I had to keep her I
had to wean her off this medication
I couldn't just stop it I had to wean
her off of it was it was I can't
remember what it was Clark it was clonic
klonopin Clemons and I think was
something like that it was it was
terrible they said that she should have
been in a coma and she had an adverse
reaction because she was allergic to it
but all those all those medications and
then all the anti-seizure medication
she's allergic to so she has these
reactions where she just goes nuts and
it's awful and I mean what am I supposed
to do you know I don't know I don't know
what to do she doesn't sleep you know
but but when she's any other time she's
just a sweet child you know and I was
told when she was 2 years old that she'd
never walked she'd never talk she'd
never do anything she wouldn't be able
to look she's 16 years old she's walking
she's talking she's actually she's she's
got a job three hours nine fabulous yeah
she works at chick-fil-a yeah but she's
she's wonderful she's on a special needs
cheerleading team I mean she's yes it's
amazing but she's had meningitis several
times you know and I mean I I understand
you know I understand the battles that
the the the battles with the with the
health and everything I'm it's
it's tough it's so tough it's so tough
with it but I don't understand what the
what you were talking about with the
acid dr. Kent can better explain my I
learned the hard way but it's it's not
something well understood I think so
I'll defer to him well one of the areas
of medical focus now cutting edge areas
is the microbiome and you know
functional alternative practitioners in
the past have always known how important
our second brain or gut is and now
there's a lot of science that recognizes
how important the microbiome is in
relation to our health you know there's
a hundredfold more bacteria in our GI
tract that make up the microbiome than
every cell in our body and we share
genetic material we talk genetically
with the bacteria that make up our
microbiome you can think of it like an
estuary you know it's a complex system
that utilizes all kinds of things in
order to make things work to balance we
know that cannabis is an adaptogenic
herb and adaptogens help our body
reach homeostasis or that balance that
physiology is always looking for and so
Reagan had a situation where they you
know regular Western medicine looks at
the body's response to things it doesn't
like bonds by stopping stomach acid well
stomach acid is the primary protection
to infection being introduced to the
GI track and when you take a members ole
which is a proton pump inhibitor and you
stop the body's ability to create acid
and protect the GI tract all of a sudden
you set it up for what Reagan had which
was an infection she wasn't able to
protect herself and ultimately that
required you know a fecal transplant to
ultimately help try and recreate that
microbiome that would then protect her
because of the challenges that she has
with her immune system so we're running
short on time and so what I'd like to do
is just give each of you a minute or two
in order to just you know send a message
out to our audience you know as a mom
someone that's that has daily challenges
that clearly you have all done wonderful
things with your children because they
probably wouldn't be alive if they
didn't have you as a as a mom taking
care of them paying attention
challenging and fighting for their
well-being and my heart goes out to all
of you I've got to to engage with a
couple of you on a friendship and a
medical basis in and I feel privileged
to have been able to help facilitate
some of to help answer some of those
those physiologic in treatment
challenges that you guys have had to
deal with so why don't we start with
Hera and then we'll go to dawn and then
we'll end with Jenelle so what would you
like to end with to our audience I think
the most important thing
as a mom whether this is a new diagnosis
that you're dealing with or a diagnosis
that has been going on for several years
follow your instinct don't be afraid to
try don't be afraid to reach out there
is no milligram dosing even for Big
Pharma it's a guessing game but you know
your child and you know I think it was
dot or Janelle that said like you you
just you dose from your heart you know
what they feel like you know what they
look like you know what they need
because it is a lock-and-key system
everything is a little bit different for
everyone so don't be fearful and as a
good friend of mine once said you know
there's no recorded passings from
cannabis I mean this is a medicine grown
in the ground for us to utilize and work
we haven't been utilizing it properly
and we're just scratching the surface
the way my son we utilize it for my son
is completely different than my daughter
I never thought I'd be standing in the
kitchen and look over at my daughter and
say don't forget to take your tincture
before you go to school I mean that is
just I it was a surreal moment that I
ended up texting a friend of mine that
helped me to really wrap my head around
this and I said you know those words
came out of my mouth or my daughter
texting me mom I'm feeling very anxious
before I go to this can I take more I
mean it's it's insane but the norm
becomes a different norm and you know
the MRIs and the EEG s and the gut
health and everything it all comes
together because the CBD and the THC
does help the guy does help the
swallowing does help the reflux it's
it's a domino effect for every single
part of your body healthy part of your
body not just your brain it's
you know like I said it's lock and key
it's the entourage effect and it's
something that's real so I guess my
biggest thing is don't be fearful dawn
I'm Heron Heron pretty much nailed it on
that took the words right out of my
mouth yeah you have to go with with with
your heart I mean you know nobody knows
your child more than you do and and you
are your child's advocate you're your
your best child I'd get nobody can fight
for your child more than you can and and
I mean my mom is the one that told me
that she's the one that that really
taught me that and who else is gonna
fight for your child more than you and
nobody knows your child more than you
and and you know you know how your child
feels no matter what any doctor says you
know you know how your child is feeling
you know how you if if if it's okay or
or if it's if something is is feeling
okay or the dose is just good or not
good enough or or too much of any
medication and or if it's working or not
and just everything is just go with your
gut and and it's medically I mean I'm a
Hera I'm with you I never thought I'm a
thumb an ex-police officer I never
thought that I'd be you know I mean it's
not like I'm standing out on a corner
you know yes
Selin or anything getting getting it
buying it and getting it for my kid or
anything but yeah you I never thought
that I would be giving it to my child
and and in a million years I never
thought that but but it's it's what
works it's what works and and you do
what you can for your child
and I do it a million times over then
then some of the medications alright
well Janelle you got a couple minutes
how would you like down I think we're
living in unprecedented time in history
I don't think anyone needs to be worried
about is the science there don't let
someone scare you because your syndrome
or diagnosis is different than the ones
that other people have had success with
I think at the end of the day you know
the science is starting to catch up and
there is power in numbers
and I remember anecdotally being Reagan
had just tanked we had gone to Mayo
Clinic in Rochester in the dead of
winter and she was she was intubated and
seizing out of control with influenza A
and in her little sleep coma and I had
to convince Mayo Clinic to allow me to
dose whatever I was getting sent from
Colorado and in whatever amount I wanted
and you know I just I feel like again we
go back to this thing of we do not need
to ask permission to do what is right
for our children there is power in the
numbers there's power in the science
those practitioners can go and find the
science it exists and if you do find
yourself in a really scary acute
situation don't be afraid to stand up
for your rights even in a hospital that
doesn't allow it you would be surprised
at what is allowed if you come in with
confidence and with with a genuine heart
because it really did make critical
differences and in Reagan's ability to
get through the infections that she was
getting through and the subsequent words
that were caused from it but um you know
for us we've been in we've been in this
game now for four or five years and in
the beginning it was just about you know
I like to think of three major things
that you have to think of anytime you're
you're dabbling in cannabis and it's you
have to find your cannabinoids like what
what's gonna be the right mix for your
kid yeah are they THC dominant are they
CBD dominant do they need CVG there's
there's such a breadth and depth of
cannabinoids and underneath that the
complexity gets more when you
to think about terpenes and strains and
and then don't forget delivery method we
what works for my daughter four years
ago if we had stuck with that and said
that was the be-all end-all and never
changed or adjusted we she wouldn't be
here today don't be afraid to modify any
medication whether it's Pharma or
natural need to be modified because the
body is changing if your body goes
through an acute situation and it is in
trauma what was working for them is no
longer gonna work because they're
literally their body and brain has
changed no and sometimes we can't we
can't avoid those forces in our case it
was that we contracted c-diff and then
we were living in a feedeth world for
the last two years but you know
ultimately I adjust medication depending
on what Regan's going through and acute
situations mean more medication and
different delivery methods so don't
forget about delivery method find your
cannabinoid ratio and underneath that
you can start to really get granular on
what works for your kid but don't be
overwhelmed by it ultimately dose until
you find something that works the worst
thing that you could do going into
cannabis is not find support because you
need to talk to someone Facebook groups
are great but there's a ton of marked
bulk multi-level marketing going on
right now where someone's gonna message
you say CBD worked for me it changed my
life and it's gonna work for you and
ultimately this is medicine it's not a
business and anyone promising you cures
or something is gonna work perfectly you
need a mom you need someone to talk to
um I can't underestimate ease sake this
is all we're all paving a new way and in
20 years the world will look different
but for right now for your child you
need support and so go find out support
in any form you can and don't be afraid
to keep trying that's it thank you thank
you so much well I'd like to thank our
panelists for their normative answers
and thank you to our wonderful audience
today for your thought-provoking
questions you may continue submitting
questions
and our speakers will follow up via
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we'll see you next time